en este vídeo y en los siguientes dos
vídeos vamos a ver un buen de cálculos
sobre estos datos que tenemos aquí y
espero que en el camino a través de
todos estos cálculos que vamos a hacer
les dé una mejor comprensión intuitiva
sobre el análisis de la varianza pero lo
primero que vamos a ver en este vídeo es
la suma total de cuadrados la stc así lo
voy a denotar la stc la suma total de
cuadrados no es más menos que el
numerador de la varianza es decir me voy
a tomar la diferencia entre la media y
cada uno de estos datos y lo voy a
llevar al cuadrado y para finalizar voy
a sumar cada uno de los resultados que
voy a obtener desde cuenta que es lo
mismo que la varianza solamente que no
está dividido entre los grados de
libertad o entre la cantidad de datos
que tenemos menos uno pero bueno antes
de encontrar la suma total de cuadrados
lo primero que hay que calcular es la
media y en este caso la media va a ser
igual que la gran media la gran media la
voy a definir como la media de las
medias de cada uno de los datos es decir
esto es lo mismo que 32
ya esto le voy a sumar los datos de la
segunda columna es decir más 5 + 34 y a
esto le voy a sumar los datos de la
tercera columna más 5 6 7 y a todo esto
lo voy a dividir entre la cantidad de
datos que yo tengo que son 9 muy bien
tres más dos más uno es lo mismo que 6
534 es lo mismo que 12 y por último 56
+7 es lo mismo que 18 entonces al final
voy a tener 6 más 12 más 18 y 6 más 12
más 18 es lo mismo que 36 36 si lo
divido entre 94 entonces mi gran media
es lo mismo que 4 y observen que la gran
media no es más menos que la media de
todos los datos o dicho de otra manera y
lo que yo quería comentarles es que es
la media de las medias fíjense bien voy
a tomar la media de la primera columna
tres más dos más uno es seis y dividido
entre tres me da dos ahora me voy a
tomar la media de la segunda columna es
53 4 que me da 12 ya lo habíamos
calculado
vídeo entre tres datos me va a dar
cuatro y ahora voy a calcular la media
de la tercera columna que es 5 6 7 que
es lo mismo que 18 y dividido entre 3 me
va a dar 6 entonces ya tengo la media de
cada una de mis columnas que va a pasar
se basa con la media de estas medias es
decir saco la media de 24 y 6 pues suma
2 me dan 12 246 me dan 12 y divididos
entre 3 me va a dar 4 es decir que la
gran media no era ni más ni menos que la
media de cada una de las medias muy bien
ya que tengo a la media total a la gran
media entonces yo ya puedo sacar la suma
total de cuadrados que va a ser ni más
ni menos que tomar cada uno de los datos
y restarle la media y ya estoy llevando
al cuadrado y después tomarme la suma de
todos estos resultados es decir 3 menos
4 elevado al cuadrado más 2 menos 4
elevado al cuadrado más 1 menos 4
elevado al cuadrado y darse cuenta que
en este caso estoy haciendo la
diferencia de la primera columna menos
la media y todo elevado al cuadrado
ahora para la segunda columna yo
obtendría 5 menos 4 elevado al cuadrado
más
3 - 4 elevado al cuadrado más 4 4
elevado al cuadrado y para la tercera
columna voy a obtener 5 menos 4 elevado
al cuadrado más 6 menos 4 elevado al
cuadrado más 7 menos 4 elevado al
cuadrado y esto que va a ser igual
3 - 4 es menos 1 elevado al cuadrado me
da 1 positivo +2 menos 4 es menos 2
elevado al cuadrado me da 41 menos 4 es
menos 3 elevado al cuadrado me va a dar
9 y ahora con color morado me queda 5
menos 4 es uno positivo elevado al
cuadrado sigue siendo uno positivo
3 - 4 - 1 elevado al cuadrado es uno
positivo y 4 - 4 es cero elevado al
cuadrado cero déjenme poner este cero
aquí ya esto hay que sumarle 5 menos 4
que es 1 elevado al cuadrado que me da
otra vez 16 menos 4 elevado al cuadrado
que me da 4 y 7 menos 4 elevado al
cuadrado que me da otra vez 9 es decir
13 elevado al cuadrado que es 9 y
cuántos esto
149 es lo mismo que 14 entonces todo
esto de aquí es 14 y ya decimos porque
también los del final también suman 14
14 9 también es 14 entonces también lo
voy a poner aquí
estos son 14 y 11 es 2 14 14 es 28 más 2
me da 30 entonces el resultado de la
suma total de cuadrados es 30 y darse
cuenta que este número 30 es el
numerador de la varianza si nosotros
quisiéramos sacar en este momento la
varianza nos tendremos que fijar en los
grados de libertad que hay y cómo
sacamos los grados de libertad bueno
primero dense cuenta cuántos grupos
tenemos supongamos que tenemos m grupos
que de aquí acaso m grupos le voy a
poner solamente una m y cada uno de esos
grupos tiene en de datos por lo tanto de
aquí hasta abajo va a haber en de datos
por cada grupo en total cuántos datos
tendríamos pues tendríamos m por n
entonces son m grupos y cada uno de
ellos va a tener en edad
lo voy a poner aquí para no confundirnos
y entonces el total de todos los datos
que tendríamos serian m por ende que en
este caso son 9 bueno los grados de
libertad siempre se consiguen sacando m
por n 1 en este caso particular serían 9
menos uno que es 8 y seguramente ustedes
están preguntando por qué los grados de
libertad son 8 y no son 9 que es la
cantidad de datos que tenemos bueno la
respuesta es la siguiente si nosotros
conocemos a la gran media y además
conocemos a todos nuestros datos excepto
a uno podríamos obtener ese dato que nos
falta de una manera muy sencilla es
decir podemos prescindir de cualquiera
de nuestros datos es decir si a nosotros
nos faltará el 7 o en su dado caso el 3
o cualquiera de nuestros datos en
nuestra información pero lo que si no
conocemos son todos los datos excepto a
1 y además la gran media podríamos
encontrar ese dato que nos falta de una
manera muy sencilla esto también lo
podríamos decir de otra manera si
nosotros conocemos la gran media y
además conocemos mejor n menos uno de
nuestros datos entonces ya tenemos la
información completa es decir que me
ponen en menos uno solo
de libertad de nuestra información y
bueno ya con esto podríamos sacar la
varianza si nosotros quisiéramos sacar
la varianza tendríamos que dividir el 30
que era la suma total de cuadrados y
dividirlo entre 8 que es la cantidad de
grados de libertad ojos recuerden que
tenemos 8 grados de libertad porque
teníamos 9 datos por lo tanto la
varianza total sería 30 octavos y bueno
por este vídeo va a ser toda la
información que les voy a dar en el
siguiente vídeo voy a analizar qué pasa
con la varianza total o qué pasa con la
suma total de cuadrados o dicho de otra
manera qué pasa con la variación total a
comparación de la variación de cada uno
de estos grupos es decir si comparamos
la variación total con respecto a la
variación de cada uno de estos grupos y
además nos fijamos en la variación entre
cada uno de los grupos vamos a obtener
la suma total de cuadrados eso es lo que
vamos a intentar hacer en el próximo
vídeo
y bueno con todo esto vamos a poder
construir una mejor intuición acerca de
lo que es el análisis de varias ao en la
nova y vamos a poder entender mejor
estos conceptos nos vemos